paris 20e arrondissement aujourd'hui il
n'a pas tout à domicile il n'a est une
fille du soleil elle est née dans
l'archipel des tuamotu en polynésie
française elle est arrivée en métropole
dans les années 80
[Musique]
chez in a tatoué est une vocation loin
de la mode c'est un élément essentiel de
sa culture d'origine ce qui fait d'elle
l'une des meilleures tatoueuse
polynésienne de la capitale pour inna le
tatouage c'est un livre ouvert sur le
corps quand un homme
avait
vécu un quelque chose d'un sa vie
pouvait être un exploit en tout cas le
tatouage était fait pour figer 7
cet acte de bravoure qui là
qu'il a réalisé donc
il se tatouer et en rajouter comme ça
d'autres d'autres tatouages sur son
corps jusqu'à ce que ben ya plus de
place
parfait
cinq heures de travail pour réaliser les
contours de ce tatouage rendez vous dans
quelques semaines pour le remplissage
pour bien comprendre la signification du
tatouage nous retrouvons ina dans le 15e
arrondissement
ce matin elle a rendez vous avec les
amène à un jeune tahitien yamakasi de 23
ans ils se rendent chez yannick un ami
de longue date
[Musique]
et émana a été adopté par une famille
métropolitaine à l'âge de 4 ans c'est en
grandissant qu'il a ressenti le besoin
de se replonger dans sa culture
d'origine
après dix ans de recherche il a retrouvé
ses parents haïtiens un moment fort
qu'il a voulu marquer au fer rouge le
requin signifie le côté maternel de la
famille oui a donc
la famille la raie manta nous ne
concerne même les vagues qui soit son
tatouage est en fait reprenant quelque
chose c'est mes allers-retours
ma recherche et le dauphin août c'est le
symbole paternel
c'est l'occasion pour chacun d'évoquer
son parcours à chaque étape importante
de la vie son tatouage j'aime bien ce
qui m'a demandé mais il tati
mais jusque quand tu as l'intention
d'utiliser ton corps comme un brouillon
nous sommes rue monsieur le prince à
deux pas du jardin du luxembourg au
coeur du quartier étudiant
dans cet appartement transit depuis 60
ans les jeunes polynésiens de passage en
métropole leïla est arrivé à paris il ya
deux ans étudiante en doctorat d'arts
plastiques à la sorbonne c'est elle qui
est responsable du foyer 4e 5e qui
arrive demain et puis la tahitienne en
se on se met tous maison à côté des
autres à paris fait froid et tout comme
ça sans garde la chaleur sans cesse
pour ces jeunes insulaires le premier
contact avec la capitale est un choc
fait arrivé déjà en tant que
polynésienne j'ai vu qu'il y avait plein
de
de cultures différents et je me suis dit
mais comment ils font que le vivre les
uns sur les autres le con ça se passe
doit y avoir des guerres dans un même
lieu et en fait non ils vivent tous
ensemble et moi je me suis dit ben et
comment moi je vais fait pour vivre pour
exister au milieu de tous ces racines
polynésiennes sont le point de départ de
son travail artistique l'alsace exprime
à travers certains éléments clés de sa
culture comme le tatouage au moins les
tatouages les tellement sacré je pense
que je saurai pas
je n'arrive pas à me décider enfin je
sais pas quel tatouage mais attribuées
donc je sais pas du tout ce que j'ai
douanes je veux droit de porter parce
que c'est pas juste un effet de mode
pour moi cocteau tournoi
hockey
et ça signifie quoi celui là
ben moi j'ai pas de tatouage par contre
j'ai trouvé un moyen d'affronter
tatouage en faisant des projections des
tatouages sur le visage sa technique de
tatouage est particulière leila dessine
sur une plaque en verre et projette
grâce aux rayons du soleil des symboles
sur sa peau donc ici on voit la plaque
parce que cette photographie là on me
voit transparence derrière ici ce petit
symbole est là c'est le sexe féminin ont
tatouage marquisien quitter son archipel
n'a pas été facile mais c'est ici à
paris que son travail a trouvé tout son
sens c'est fou comme les gens à
l'extérieur ça peut plus encore plus la
culture parce que quand on est à
l'intérieur nous on appelle ça le pito
isme tenté noyées à l'intérieur et ben
tu t'en fous par contre une fois que tu
es alex terry a été très très loin tu es
là tu te dis me mens il me manque
quelque chose et c'est là que ça sort
encore plus
aujourd'hui la isa est une artiste
reconnue cette année elle a même été
choisi pour représenter la polynésie à
l'exposition universelle de shanghai
on retrouve ina ce soir c'est football à
l'occasion de la coupe de l'outre-mer la
polynésie affronte la nouvelle calédonie
la communauté s'est donné rendez-vous à
longjumeau en banlieue parisienne
direction les vestiaires inna est venu
rejoindre les joueurs pour le chant de
l'hymne eaux territoriales quoi qu'il
arrive
[Musique]
ici la passion c'est le ballon rond
alors on en retrouve forcément des
traces sur le corps des joueurs j'étais
le capitaine des u20 g alors né j'ai
fait j'aimais bien mais maintenant place
à ses vues côté gauche
ça symbolise toujours quelque chose quoi
donc maintenant à la phase de brassage
il a voulu
on est à la coupe du monde des u20 je
n'avais pas et enlever non je vous
symbolisez d'entraîneur
ce soir là les dieux du stade était avec
les polynésiens avec à la clé une
victoire aux tirs au but
et surprise dans les vestiaires pour
fêter le succès l'ambiance est pieuse à
la tahitienne
mais si vous le résultat final tu nous
appellent et nous le dire encore une
fois de la saison qu'on avait une dent
cette semaine
[Musique]